[Music]
also
at
least they
passed
with it
's fine
what things are going to improve
i
yes
hello
and
that's fine
thanks
these taquitos where papa but there are
different stews stews are like
preparations like pork rinds in
green sauce  etcetera but these are my
favorites
and
from pits burgos forward base mentor is
my great life
I'm from m2
[Music]
ai and they tell me
a week
oi
and
ah so
far this year it's
going well
[Music]
that's why you know bad existing zrt
ah
why
is it always
this way
[Music]
ah
surely christian
dates
[Music]
world is gone
and I
tango
there is something that will make
this regular cell down
like every situation
[Music]
and  now
hello
from
behind add footsteps
[Music]